[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sup y'all we have a very special guest
here today
Chris [ __ ] Din aka the dawn
from Saigon that's not the boy
nobody Hanoi the [ __ ] not Pitt that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] ha ha I'm trying to turn you
into a rapper right now
a Vietnamese rapper so when I first
moved to LA I used to live in a south
pass and I used to always come here for
my Vietnamese fixes and there was a very
cute girl that was here that never left
when I saw her and every day I would try
to make her laugh she never did none
nothing very awkward I would come in hey
what's going on it's been a [ __ ] long
time terrible joke by the way
and I thought that terrible joke would
at least give her an awkward laugh no
she gave me the finger with her eyes so
uh we're back here we are going to try
different types of fun different
delicious foods my favorite booths and
of course Chris I didn't even tell him
that we were coming here but he's going
to let us know what it is to be the
Denise yeah oh boy
I'm not qualified for that job but yeah
let's go
[Music]
because growing up and I've mentioned
this multiple times I had the biggest
thing for Vinny's women I don't know how
this trailed into this but I thought I
could impress them by learning how to
make a delicious bowl of pho and that is
[ __ ] is not easy no but can you I've
tried and I know I added the right
ingredients right and I thought I was
doing everything right and then they
just turned out to be a like five gallon
pot of [ __ ] I don't think like many of
these people know the history of [ __ ]
and I don't know why I learned it as if
I eat in the history to know how to make
an issue actually tell me I'm not quite
sure I know the history of apparently
bob was is actually a northern
Vietnamese dish that moved in to the
south is so far back versus gone there
so traditionally with northern style ah
it's it's very clean it's very simple
right so it's a relatively new dish it's
not that culturally embedded I think
what people have derived is that it was
developed during you know the French
colonization hunt right right so when
they were colonizing Vietnam beef at
that time wasn't really it was it was it
was people with beef but it wasn't even
to that kind of extend the cattle was
used more for for labor for work right
right and so that's why when people look
at the brought that kind of looks like a
continent right so very clear brought
for a lot of like the grime and the fat
is taken out of it so a super clear very
oh yeah and then later on when it
started going towards the south that's
when they started adding vegetables to
it the bean sprouts the mint the basil
you know and everything else like that
which is the spa that we're used to
eating which is like what they serve
here right so my my five brothers turn
into ass I doubt it
I'm curious know it just wasn't good but
I think maybe you have high standards
maybe that's what it is because you've
been you've been I'm sure you've been
eating for us since you were to impress
young Vietnamese women definitely
[Music]
Chris let's have you tried the spring
roll all right Ellis what you feel about
it
my mom makes this at home all the time I
really think that is that staple Vinny's
dish that everybody is yeah look at him
he's even did it love white people style
where he just dipped it and he didn't
want to doubled it what's wrong with you
man you just came from Vietnam I did I
don't know why I know I feel absolutely
I never do it just like you thank you
never at first but I don't know why I
did there's something about being here
with you that just pressured me into
hearing that cheers this spring Rome hmm
pleasure
mm-hmm I'm not gonna use the fork back
look how dare you I'm also sharing is
caring
I'm also very sick it's perfectly fine
my I told you I eat a lot of
preservatives my body can be preserved
it's super light mm-hmm I like the chewy
texture of the rice paper is one of my
favorite like things divided - it's kind
of like an edible condom hmm my fault
I've always wondered well you either
that's like people in Trojan the edible
spring roll condom think about that [ __ ]
this is our broken rice plate Chris
let's have you dig into that okay do you
ever wonder what it was like in that
moment that someone accidentally found a
fermented fish and somehow got it in his
mouth and he's like oh my god I think
that amazing food was created by drunk
people cuz ya don't have to be you have
to be bold enough to say like you know
what this tastes like the back of my
[ __ ] mouth yeah after I passed out
for six hours yeah this might be good on
my food right that's some crazy people
[ __ ] even your theory dude even like
Korean the fermented bean paste who the
[ __ ] walking's and rots it till it looks
like [ __ ] it literally looks like a pot
of trivia and they go he's so good yeah
because you wear programs to stay away
stay away from that stuff because it
could potentially kill us
yeah about some point you were either so
drunk or so hungry or high you had no
choice but to eat that
realize it didn't kill you he's gonna
add the green onions cool the astringent
green onions the pickled vegetables
right there
when you close your eyes do you see
Vietnam mm-hmm the the dress with the
collar that goes all the way up into the
neck with a nice straw hat you're
wearing it thank you
ello is speaking out featuring his
beautiful lady and them so she expanded
400 pounds and there's me with like this
bright red lipstick duh uh child let her
be enemies is really good thank you
I try to perfect it for the longest time
just to impress the ladies right I saw
my Columbia huh sir
how come you not drinking beer I
wouldn't know how to continue a
conversation after that the who feel
which is one of my personal favorites
yeah we are going to add the little bit
of acidity to it with the lime cover his
eyes because I'm not trying to destroy
it damn this is a strong line I just
embarrassed myself Chris take a bite of
this barbecue pork shrimp crab claw
seafood broth green onions as you notice
they don't give you a plate of the
typical culprits that you see in the
beef broth which is the bean sprouts the
Vietnamese cilantro the perilla leaf
this one you have it like this you don't
add that [ __ ] just a little bit of line
the jalapenos like this in a very long
time yes so I'm excited
enjoy joy I know man
conky how's that very good it's very
good right nice and salty quite
delicious this is the ultimate test
we're gonna call this Chris didn't goes
to Vietnam even though you were in
Vietnam hey let's go to Vietnam sometime
I'm down I just don't want to go cuz I'm
afraid I'm a get my kidneys harvested so
yeah no no let's go I'm down and you can
be my tour of that everybody went up to
America because I'm hella fat everyone
wanted royalty oh it's so funny because
you you you can't eat but without that I
never put that in my phone oh really
yeah I think it's blasphemous really so
here's the thing too I see people look
at this bullets all right before they
even taste the broth they start jumping
all the [ __ ] yeah and I'm like yo man
this there's a chef behind it would slap
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you how dare you
they're like you know what cool holy
[ __ ] but you didn't even taste it how do
you know you need this year you [ __ ]
dare you
guilty goofy I'm gonna twist you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I'm now
today recognizing the my wrong ways yes
so I'd like to do it the right way today
there is a history behind this food my
friend writes to them in a little
embarrassed let's have an aside the
broth first before you bastardize it
with your hot sauce you son of a [ __ ]
I'm so embarrassed
I'm like very embarrassed okay
[Music]
silky mouthfeel to that broth how is
that very good you taste the the star
anise the cinnamon cardamom which are
the main culprits of this broth that you
taste that beefiness little droplets of
fat on that [ __ ] now let's have you try
the noodle and the beef together so with
our y-yeah why did I ever at Sarat
cetera there's pureness to it so what I
like to do if you want that heat just
add a little bit the chili satay it has
a nice like mouthfeel to it I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go off pure and eat it there
we go
[Music]
how do you like it
it's good
don't need any about that's what I'm
saying so if you go to a fun place and
you feel like you need to add like all
this extra accoutrements or condiments
or broth sucks ass I think is I like the
way like the cook kind of intends it to
be so I think that's a lot of easy so in
a lot of American food there's ketchup
there's this sauces order that's
actually French - but you add things to
it to kind of heighten the flavor right
I think the great thing about a group
it's there for you it's made ready to go
right so it was kind of odd for me to
watch people just bastardize this week
that somebody spent like they'll pass
like day or two making and then you just
throw your [ __ ] into it
I should slice you in half mom I'm sorry
I bet every time your mom's are you what
the [ __ ] man mommy make this for three
day and you're going to do that to move
kill yourself and then we have the
tomato boom real good move the crab
rangoon tomato bot broth base let's see
you put these rice moves a little bit
different than the lighter can here but
it's basically mashed up crap bodies
that sounded terrible I should never
write a menu all right here we go
definitely smashed up my body yeah it
has a really seafoody flavor if you
don't like seafood you're really not
going to like this now one of my
favorite favorite favorite favorite
favorite things to drink is to have
Vinny's coffee also known as enemy's
crack now I know that you guys had
coffee before if you need that caffeine
boost first of all I will put this out
that unless they want to sponsor me [ __ ]
redbull have some of this right here and
as you can see slow drip espresso
[ __ ] now this is that coffee
press that we see right and which people
don't do is give that little extra
squeeze and you know that's Asian people
we don't like to waste we like to get
our money's worth even though the [ __ ]
wasn't that expensive at all I like to
just get that [ __ ] right in there just
it's essentially a few espressos with
condensed milk on the bottom which is
where you get that delicious
sweetness from you mix it first you
don't want to add this before you mix it
because the condensed milk will tighten
up and seize up from the cold ice then
you'll take the I then you're
technically cafe so there
beautiful this is for you Chris no for
me thank you great color see if it does
justice okay
so much justice notice what I had to do
to mine so like I said Catholic so there
is very strong I'm like lightheaded
because I drink half of it and with the
other half I had to add water because
it's too strong for me but this [ __ ]
monster here just drank the whole thing
all that get miss centers are like you
know what guys this is too strong for me
what empty so we just got done eating at
the golden deli in Temple City it was
[ __ ] delicious see what I did that
it's nice today as you can tell Chris
knows nothing about his culture or his
cuisine even though he was just in
Vietnam not too long ago carrying dong
in his pocket two types of dong one
penis one money
[Laughter]
this is one of my favorite spots you
guys should go come and check it out is
this a sponsored video are they paying
me money to do this absolutely not I
just like supporting businesses that I
love and you know I think that when you
have great food you can really taste the
love and purpose behind it and that's
what the one of the things that I enjoy
why do people become great chefs or
cooks because there's purpose its
purpose in the food you feel the warmth
I consider afar like a mother's one kiss
on your forehead it envelops your body
makes you feel like you're a good human
being even though you've done terrible
things in your life I just think it is
there you go and that's coming from
Chris Din a class 10 rapist
[Music]
Oh
[Music]